man who is back here on the show I think
this might be appearance either tus and
his third appearance in remarkably he
remembers every single question of every
subtle sequence in the first two artists
actually edited that one so you know
they said okay wait what was that then
we played it made it look like that
right so even from your playing days
from my video you remember that sort of
well to you know say how did you get
here I wouldn't be able to do that right
it's football my dad always gives me a
hard time he says you know it would be
helpful if you knew something other than
something about things other than
football I said yeah I don't think I
have enough room my brain for that
that's worked up for you it's worked out
for you something all that football in
there it's worked out except for the
last game oh gosh how do you really
think that way
do you really don't think about no no
okay certainly I think you know when you
look back at this season and really the
first couple years here couldn't be more
thankful and really excited about
attacking you know our third season in
nineteen so right obviously didn't end
the way that you wanted to but now you
you have such an appreciation for our
players our coaches and really everybody
that was so influential and helping the
season be as special as it was and in
the way that it ended obviously isn't
isn't ideal but it certainly doesn't put
a damper on you know the appreciation
for the entirety of the journey well I
know we were just showing for the radio
audience you were just showing the
stadium it's just up the road from here
and it's going up and it's significant
and you know the what you talk about in
terms of special last year's not just
wins and losses I haven't had it really
much of a conversation about this with
you you did call in during the season
for a few minutes while you were amidst
obviously coaching a season but this to
me was the year the Rams became a Los
Angeles team yeah because of what was
happening in Thousand Oaks with the
shooting what was going on with the
fires in the way that the Rams responded
in the way that this community responded
to the Rams away that the Rams were part
of the community was going on how
difficult was that for you with the
Mexico game and then obviously was going
on with the field and you were out in
collar
to get ready for the altitude yeah can
you had that game on a Monday night here
anyway you know I'll tell you what rich
if anything it gave you a perspective
you know cuz I know you know I'm guilty
of you get so caught up in your own
little world of football and then you
realize when some of these things occur
that that affect a lot of the people
that you love and you care about
especially when it's so close to your
community and really if anything it gave
you a greater appreciation for the
caliber of men and people that we have
in our building watching the way that
our core leaders responded when you had
the shootings and he have Andrew
Whitworth get up there and address the
team and you know those things resonate
more than anything else watching the way
that our organization and mr. Kroenke
and and a lot of people were so helpful
and when the fires occurred and so many
of our guys are evacuated out of their
houses you know you find a way to
accommodate them in the hotels and then
you have the things occur where we're in
Colorado Springs you come back and you
play in Kansas City when you're
anticipating or you come back play
Kansas City at home when you're
anticipating playing in Mexico City but
the way that our guys just seamlessly
handled it and they use the platform
that we do have to really you know do
something special you know for things
that are a lot bigger than football was
what resonated more than anything love
Whitworth he's been here I love that guy
he's a special man Congrats on having
him come back ya know that was big it
was you know what's funny rich is is he
knew right after that that he was going
to come back I think that he wanted to
wait a little bit to be sure but even
walking right off the field and talking
to him you know in the few days after
the Super Bowl he said I think I would
know if it was done and INRI he really
played his best football at the end I
think there's still a passion and the
way that he pours into guys you know you
talk about getting a unique perspective
on leadership where you know behind the
scenes the way that he's individually
able to affect and influence his
teammates and it doesn't necessarily
always have to be from the front and and
that's something that is pretty powerful
to see he just has a natural way about
himself where he's so empathetic and
it's it's been good you know he's helped
me in a lot of ways that I don't even
know if he realizes you're the Los
Angeles Rams head coach Sean so how did
he how what do you mean by that how he
just watching the way that he's led you
I think you know just some of the things
that just naturally come to mind where
he's always thinking of others first and
you know sometimes innately and it's
embarrassing you know sometimes you're
innately selfish and you got to really
go out of your way to say like hey this
is the right way we want to do things
and you never regret doing things for
other people and Andrews just got a
natural way about that you know the
empathy is the best way I can describe
it you know he's so empathetic he always
looks at it from other people's
perspective and and the ability to do
that where it's just that's just who he
is I think that resonates with people
and watching the way that he's led you
know has helped been a positive
influence on me where you say man that's
that's real that's authentic that's
genuine and that's what it looks like to
do it the right way well he was an
awesome he was one of the guys who again
we had him on the show right after the
NFC Championship game win where he was
like okay hold on a minute we know that
that pass interference yeah should have
been called but what about everything
else beforehand they could have beaten
this after how was it for you to be
sitting there thinking as you were
getting ready for your biggest game of
your life that a lot of people thought
you didn't belong there you didn't
deserve it you know what I think that
that was a play but there was a lot of
things that occurred in that game that
led to different and you know outcomes
and and we didn't we didn't let that
affect our preparation going into the
superb did you use that though no not
really because know what we said is hey
this is a situation that occurred and
we're not going to allow it to be any
bit of a distraction as we get ready to
try to go beat the Patriots and
certainly you're gonna you you can go
back and look at it and you know it
helped our team in terms of the momentum
at that point whether that directly
affected exactly what the outcome was
like Andrew said there was a lot of
plays that occurred afterwards but I
don't think anybody would shy away from
the fact that saying yet there was
contact before all those things but you
know for us we didn't allow it to be a
distraction and it wasn't something that
bothered us at all what about you and
your role in getting replay changed were
you were you at the forefront of that
too or you were just listening to
everything coming in at the owners
meeting a couple weeks ago yeah it was
great you know I think the biggest thing
rich is is you want to see the game not
miss plays like that I don't think there
was any coach that sat in that
any owner general manager that didn't
agree that you know the egregious you
know the clear and obvious however you
wanted to find what that play was you
know we we've got the technology we've
got the people that we can avoid missing
those types of things and I think this
is a clear-cut step in the right
direction to avoid those types of things
and you know I'll be interested to see
how it is totally implemented specific
to some of the new changes but
absolutely you want to see the plays
that are that are clear and obvious you
know officiated the right way and even
though that play did help us and that
was one of the main sticking points
because it occurred in an NFC
Championship game you know I thought
Jason Garrett said it said it best when
he said you know you got four teams
playing at the end you know two great
teams in the New Orleans Saints in the
LA Rams it was a great back and forth
game and really the only thing that
you're talking about is that play and
there's too many good things that our
game has to offer to let that be kind of
the headline when we can you know
correct some of those things but it does
put it in your lap a little bit here
Sean McVeigh Rams head coach because
look you don't have the greatest seat in
the house I mean you're right there I
mean I got a lot going on obviously
going on since you're also mindful of
what's happening on the offensive side
of the ball something could happen
completely on the other side of the fair
how are you going to throw a challenge
flag and whether you thought dpi should
have been called yeah it wasn't or
that's a great there's gonna be a
strategic approach that we take
especially because of the types of calls
when you can actually put a flag on the
field but you know you got a you got the
ability to click back and forth and we
have somebody up top that's responsible
for getting that communicated to you
yeah ironically and it was there's that
person who's yeah you know I've got some
guys on defense you know where you know
I communicate with our guy Jed fish up
top and he does a good job of you know
kind of putting flags on the field some
of the game management stuff specific to
timeouts and all that but then you know
when he's up there and you know he's a
little bit more directly involved with
the offense we got a couple coaches
Chris Shula Aubrey Pleasant that
Bogardus that on defensive side when
they're able to see something if it's
not Jed he gets that communicated to me
so that you know we can be timely with
those decisions and it's obvious you
know you it's great to have a first
class
caller sitting to my right to ask this
question how do you think the offensive
pass interference aspect of this is
gonna affect do you think you're gonna
see a little bit more a fewer picks
stuff like that I mean is it gonna be a
little more vigilant on the part of a
play caller absolutely you know and I
think the thing that you've got to make
a decision on is you know that all right
you get really two challenges and then a
third if you end up getting those first
two right and how specific do you want
to be with what determines whether you
would challenge something in the first
half or not because some of those
explosive screens or those pick type
plays like you talked about where if it
occurs pass a yard and you know in the
line of scrimmage and it you know ends
up being a huge play you might see guys
put the flag on the field and take back
some of those explosives that you see so
it's gonna be interesting you know and
that's something that we've talked about
as a staff already and as we get closer
to the season you have oh absolutely
because I think there's got to be you
know you've got to have a specific
approach you know there's a feel element
to it without a doubt based on the flow
of the game but you know how much you
want to put those on or what types of
plays would determine whether you use
that in the first half as opposed to
later on in the games is a big part of
you know the approach that you know we
got to decide how we want to want to do
it because if it's it is there like a
yardage chunk that that you're gonna say
over it's got to be over fifty at least
15 20 yards yeah he's a challenge flag
on a pass interference I would think I
would think it's got to be kind of an
explosive play or scoring type play in
those first half you know situations
where you know and even you look at it
okay if it's a if it's a third down and
shorter you know in that ends up keeping
a drive on the field and what type of
game is it one possession game two
possession it's just like anything else
there's so many elements to it you know
with the way that the games playing out
but but it's got to be a sequential
specific approach you want to take and
those are things that we've started
discussing already for sure
Sean McVeigh here on the Rich Eisen show
head coach of the defending NFC champion
Los Angeles Rams all right a couple of
questions about your playoff run yeah
that are burning questions and burning
coast-to-coast Todd Gurley yep was that
kid hurt during the playoffs no you know
he was obviously banged up at the end of
the year you know and I think to his
credit he did everything to get himself
ready to go head
a game against Dallas in the playoffs
where you see the explosiveness for the
35 yard touchdown run the New Orleans
game really was more of a result of how
the game played out kind of the flow of
the game we weren't able to really get
them run game going much and didn't
start out great and you know couldn't
have been more impressed with what a
stud and what a pro he was in the way
that he handled that and then in the
Super Bowl you know he made some
big-time runs really when you look at
the way that that second half started
rich he made a couple big time runs pops
a wide zone that he levels it off and
then he breaks one out on the left
sideline where Chung ended up hurting
his arm and you know there's a couple
plays here and there where it's 3-3 in
the fourth quarter he breaks a run that
ends up getting called back on holding
that you just never know but really
offensively as a whole you know everyone
may because todd has been so successful
and done such a great job the people
have a tendency to think someone was
wrong you know really it was more of I
didn't really give ourselves a chance to
get anything going so our offense didn't
produce it wasn't really Todd and the
opportunities were so limited and you
know that's where I've got to do a
better job of putting our players in
situations to make those plays this
could be coming from a fantasy football
oh yeah Allen's of the world it's just
he was so integral not just it just
seemed he touched the ball way much more
in the first 13 14 weeks and I know he
got hurt or sure here and in the
playoffs he's on a bike he's standing
with this his and his helmet underneath
is his arm
yes strange it was it was a weird deal
where you know he's so tough he's
pushing through different things is he
trying to get in for is he in your ear
or something no no Todd is a pro's Pro
and really he is he is such a mentally
and physically tough guy that he would
never be like that at all but you know
it was unique because CJ comes in did
such a good job those last couple weeks
and really it's okay how can we find a
way to make sure that were smartly
putting together game plans and
utilizing the guys because you know he
did miss those last couple games and in
an ideal scenario it plays out like
Dallas but you can expect Todd to be the
focal point of our offense again as we
move forward he's feeling good he's in a
good place you know I just think the
natural herbs and flows when he played
19 games
and I know he missed the couple with the
amount of work that he got you know it
just worked out that way at the end of
the year but he got a very similar
workload in 17 and you know the
anticipation for us is he's in a good
place he's feeling good and and he's
gonna continue to be a central part of
our offense you know going into the
nineteenth season and I don't see that
changing okay is there a possibility you
put him on a little bit more of a limit
in the first 12 weeks of the season you
know I wouldn't say that I think it's
we've just got to do a good job of
monitoring how he's feeling throughout
the season and and again it's football
and things can occur in a game that make
you maybe wake up more sore than you
were before but he's always been so good
about being able to communicate to us
and I think what you really saw was a
warrior pushing through the Philadelphia
game you know and then that led to
missing a couple games you know he's the
only one that can tell you exactly how I
was feeling but I know the way that guy
goes about his business and I have all
the confidence in the world that he's
gonna do a great job you know physically
mentally getting himself ready to go so
that he's peaking at the right time when
our first game opens up and the other
question about your postseason run other
than the final score of the Apple if you
could wave a wand and change something
either your approach your style or
anything and coming into that game
during that game what would what would
it be
Shauna clay yeah that's a good question
rich you know I think the biggest thing
is is just making sure that you know
you're giving players the clarity that
they need to have to go execute at a
high level if the game plays out maybe a
little bit different than what you
anticipated that the players you know
have an all-purpose menu some different
things where they know exactly what the
intent of your calls are as a play
caller
I thought the approach I thought our
guys were ready to go and I think really
you know you give New England credit
they did a great job and we did they do
you know what they did they did a good
job setting edges in the run game they
played good coverage top down and and
unfortunately we weren't able to really
make them pay and a large part of that
as a result of some of the plays I was
calling and that's where you say to
yourself okay if you get some of these
opportunities again how can you create
the ownership and the clarity for Jared
and the rest of our players that when
you do some of these things or when you
call some of these plays they know based
on whatever look the defense presents
there's a confidence and there's a
decisiveness that you enable them to be
able to operate with
so it's like anything else you know I
think we did a great job as a staff and
our players learning from when we lost
to Atlanta and we're gonna certainly do
the same thing and really whether you
win or lose our approach remains
consistent where we always use those as
learning opportunities and and I
couldn't be more excited about getting
going with our guys on Monday I betcha I
bet and in terms of that house Cooper
Cup he's doing good you know we're gonna
be smart and intentional about his
approach he's a guy that is gonna do
everything and that much more one of the
more conscientious players I've ever
been around
but he's attacking his rehab exactly
like I think we would all expect him to
do that the goal is making sure that
he's ready to go and you know it's the
one thing to to return to you know
competition it's another thing to return
to that types of performance level that
we expect for him and our goal is to get
him to return to performance where he's
playing at a high level week one week
one week one you think he can make it
back absolutely that's the goal and and
I think you know we're taking it a day
at a time you know that's still a long
ways away but um that one-day-at-a-time
approach and just taking those little
steps I think is gonna put him in a
position to be the Cooper cup that we
love and and we certainly missed when we
didn't have them I know he was a big
loss yeah he was obviously the other
guys that you have are talented but I he
just does so he's so smooth he knows
exactly where to go
his hands are phenomenal he's really
really you say the best he is and he's
got a great feel for the game you know I
think the rapport that he and Jared have
is is really valuable and it's something
where you know you gain such an
appreciation and that much more when you
don't have them but like you said I
thought a lot of guys got some
opportunities that they wouldn't have
had he been there and I thought they
matured and and they're gonna be big
parts of what we do as we move forward
so it's exciting for us human it's left
here with Sean McVeigh what what is the
area of improvement you think Jared Golf
needs to make serious coach here in his
year he's you know you know I mean
you're obviously attached at the hip
what is it experienced is it just that
sort of that's sort of fire where he
just feels it yeah owns it like running
for that first down and to that big that
wrapped it up yeah I mean that moment
where Golf is da man yeah does he need
that smell I think he's
ready the man you know I think he's had
a lot of moments his player you know his
teammates believe in him his coaches
believe in them and you know I think
it's just continuing to do what you do
at a higher level it's can I continue to
make great decisions can I throw us at
with accuracy and anticipation and I
think the thing that was great about him
really from the first year we were
together to last year the ownership you
know we talked about the quarterback
being an extension of the coaching staff
rich and I think he did that and I think
it's let's take the next step this year
where we've gotten you know an inventory
of defensive structures and games that
you've played now put that in the memory
bank so that when you see these similar
types of looks you say hey I've been
here before I know what types of play
calls to expect from Shaun where we're
really attached at the hip like you
mentioned so it's really just taking the
next steps you know in terms of just the
maturity and gaining that experience and
that goes the same thing for me as well
and that's what's so unique about you
know the relationship that Jared and I
have is we're going through a lot of
them the maturity if you will on kind of
the growing pains but but we sure have
had a lot of good times over these first
couple years and expect to have many
more if if we approach it the right way
okay and you added Weddell and clay max
yes people who obviously Southern
California fans know very well as if you
needed better hair I mean with you and
like us I mean those guys that's a solid
group right there you know I mean it's
like Mount Rushmore for crying out loud
I love it I mean thatthat shot of you
guys whether you got there's you on the
right less on the left and Weddell in
the center right there who do you think
what would you say one two and three
start bench cut I mean you do a start
when I got a bench one I got a cut one
okay put that up there one more time let
me see one more time here forget this
you got to go ahead hit the hit the drop
right here I had no idea on the pitches
put me miss
it's gonna be quiet or cut up all right
best hair so what you're saying do I
take it and it's it's the beard too
right yeah okay so I got up all right
I'm gonna start you Sean I mean in terms
of the hair and beard okay my
combination plus you're here so I'm
gonna start you Sean I'm gonna bench
less oh I'm gonna bench less I mean less
knees hair are you kidding me
and I again I just just saying I'm not
I'm not a Travis Bickel Mohawk guy I
don't know if I could ever pull that off
but wet oh I'm gonna just cut Weddell
like yeah you can have him I'm gonna cut
him so you can start him that's good I
know this will start Weddell I'm sure
you are absolutely that guy's a keeper
huh he's a stud he's one of those guys
we practiced against the Ravens last
year and you know I think you can get a
different perspective when you can
actually be on the field behind the
action or on the grass as a post on the
sidelines but he's always a guy that has
had such an ownership of the defense the
communication you can see this guy's got
an understanding of what offenses are
looking at how he can throw them off and
you know we've had a couple coaches Joe
Barry's been with him speak to the world
of them and I think his production
speaks for itself but then when you
spend a little bit of time with them you
talk about a guy that loves football is
very much in alignment with some of the
things that we try to you know preach on
a daily basis with their culture and
what we stand for and you know I think
really you know he's gonna be a huge
addition to us and selfishly guys like
him make you a better coach because they
keep you accountable with the questions
they have and in the experience because
of the way that he approaches the game
well a few more minutes left here with
Sean McVeigh how do you what goes
through your mind when you hear
everybody wants one of you everybody's
trying to hire a coach that's you yeah I
gotta get this guy let's you would they
want they want one of you yeah you think
of what goes through my mind is you know
it's flattering and humbling rich but
it's a result of the success we've had
as a team and you know it's just like
you know but everybody you know what
though it is true though like we got
great coaches on our staff we got good
players you know so much in alignment
with Les and his you know his group and
you know it's it's a great reflection of
our organization and what we've done and
I think you know
that's the biggest thing and to see guys
that we've worked with over the last
couple years get opportunities with Matt
and with Zack Taylor you know they're
deserving of it because of what they've
done on their own merit and when they go
in and compete for jobs people say man
we can see this guy leading our
organization and you know I'm looking
forward to seeing those guys thrive have
you told Kingsbury that he has a job
because of you - no that's cliff got his
deal on his own okay no I'm sure he did
I know yeah you you know you're you you
were knocking on his door - to join your
staff I know that so you're well he was
a he passed him the Cordish after that I
did you totally what did you do - well
uh basically you know we obviously has a
pre-existing relationship with with
Patrick mahomes he was out here doing
some things and cliff was was having
dinner with him and a group of people
and we have a mutual friend and I
tricked him into thinking that you know
he was tampering and that he was gonna
lose some pics it was what you changed
somebody somebody's name and a phone -
roger goodell our mutual friend he our
mutual friend guy named she has guessed
her we put I put his number in my phone
as roger goodell
and had him send me a text that said you
know a this is tampering you know better
than this both you know and and I showed
it to Kingsbury and I said you know mr.
Goodell he never text me I said you
better call Steve cotton right now in
his face he was like he said I thought I
was gonna throw up he's like that's
wrong I mean I couldn't let it go on for
more than 30 seconds it was it was a
good but a bad joke man I mean he's like
he ruined dinner man but it was you know
what just hearing you with Kingsbury
seen you with les Snead and seeing you
with Weddell and I feel like that
episode of Seinfeld where I'm hanging
out with the with all the beautiful
people and all the great hair right now
right all these hair all these hair guys
I feel like I'm in I'm gonna I'm in a
different club when now with Kingsbury
with the last one for you since
obviously you are not in the market for
a quarterback and the conversation
everybody's having right now a Skylar
Murray at five ten and 1/8 no we see
what he sees on tape is he set for
success in this version of the National
Football League where everybody's
Gaming offense trying to again be as
successful and as dynamic as an offense
as yours oh you're gonna work yeah yeah
I mean he to me the biggest thing is is
you know I think that he could play I
mean he's got a natural he's a natural
thrower the football you know and really
I think people have a tendency to think
you throw over people you throw through
passing lanes you can change the launch
point he's so dynamic in terms of an
athlete but you know you watch I mean
you just look at he's able to play in
rhythm he can change his arm slot in
terms of delivering balls short
intermediate down the field whether it's
Arizona or somebody you're gonna get a
quarterback that can compete and I think
you know everybody looks for comps you
know there's examples of guys that have
been you know shorter stature players
that are elite competitors that guys
have a belief when they step in the
huddle and there's a fire and there's an
understanding of the position with I'm
gonna get it done I'm gonna find a way
to distribute the ball like a point
guard I can make all the throws and then
you talk about the pressure that he can
put on the defense with his mind with
his arm in his brain and I mean in his
in his leg excuse me I mean it's it's
gonna be you know impressive watching
him do his thing just like it was in the
one year that you know he wins the
Heisman at Oklahoma it's it's uh it's
gonna be interesting to see where he
goes well I mean if he goes where we
think he goes it looks like you're gonna
have four games a year with him and
Russell Wilson I mean like Wade Wade's
give me her oppelo is pretty good I know
that with grappa but I'm just in terms
of everybody says the reason why
everybody looks at someone who's 510 and
1/8 and that checks a positive box at
the combine is because of Russell Wilson
yeah exactly both potentially yeah it's
you know what it's it's gonna be you
know it's gonna be some interesting but
even if it's not if even if he's not in
the division you know you look at a guy
like Josh Rosen and some of the things
that he did as a rookie and being able
to get you know under cliffs guidance
and tutelage it's it's gonna be a
problem either way and and you know
whether it's the Cardinals the Seahawks
or the 49ers we know we're gonna have
six really tough games next year and you
know really ten others after that well I
could talk to you all day man I
appreciate you giving time before the
offseason workout program yeah
appreciate you having a you know
and I yeah thanks for coming in and say
hi to your new stadium on the way back
make sure that you save two good seats
for those guys the guy on the left of
being the Patriot fan he might just go
to the secondary ticket market or for
half the time oh look at me selling you
down the river with me friends oh I love
it
nobody got fun you got to RAM season
ticket holders over there hate the
support and it went set buildings done
odd I might be broadcasting from there
every single every single way that would
be exciting that's what I'm being that's
the goal in the situation we'll all be
all being what is it uh Disney Stan or
whatever they're calling it or ranca
Stan or it's amazing up there God good
to see you hey appreciate you having
that Sean McVeigh the head coach of the
Los Angeles Rams
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app